the passenger train was packed with
students young people coming home after
a holiday weekend just before midnight
they slammed into a freight train a
head-on collision and then a fire that
engulfed the front carriages
we heard a big bang it was 10
nightmarish second said this man as we
were turning over we were being burned
the fire was right and left
rescue teams worked through the night
with headlamps and floodlights scouring
the mangled metal for survivors and
bodies
some passengers were reportedly thrown
through the trains windows on impact
others smashed through the glass to
escape when the sun came up the Carnage
was laid bare Greece's deadliest train
disaster in over 50 years
some survivors made it home today others
never will